welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm Benjamin Dixon filling in for David
as he travels to politican be sure to
check out his debates and panels that
he's participating in also be sure to go
over to the Benjamin Dixon show YouTube
channel as well as podcast in the last
segment I discussed the fact that the
Republican hypocrisy is in fact a
feature and it is a part of their
strategy it's not a mistake Republicans
aren't mistaken about their way of
thinking in terms of they if they're not
getting it wrong it's not something that
we can explain to them and they all of a
sudden say oh that's what's going on no
they're they're being intentionally
obtuse and they're being intentionally
hypocritical in order to accomplish
their goals that they don't quite want
to expressly say to America even though
I will say that they are getting a
little better at being transparent about
their bigotry and their barbarism all
that to set up this next story I believe
David covered in some detail yesterday
about the Republican Party getting ready
to attack in quote-unquote entitlements
Social Security Medicare Medicaid in
order to take care of the deficit that
they just created the deficit is
according to every measure out of
control the only reason I'm hesitant
about saying that it's because as we've
seen in the past there study after study
this shows that the deficits don't
actually matter and they don't actually
matter in terms of it specifically when
you're spending that money on investing
in America investing in the people it
really doesn't matter the deficit could
be used to stimulate economic growth
we've seen that through American history
but what we've also seen particularly
the ninth the 20th century but what
we've also seen is a Republican party
who will knowingly run up our deficits
for war
for a defense spending even if we're not
in war they will run up the deficits to
give billions of dollars to millionaires
and billionaires and they know this the
fact that the deficit spending is not as
precarious as they try to describe it to
be when it comes time to take care of
Americans America's responsibilities we
want to invest in education we have to
worry about the deficit you want
invest in safety nets we have to worry
about the deficits you want to make sure
that seniors who have worked their
entire lives don't have to work at
McDonald's and have to be greeters I
mean at Walmart in order to just survive
do you know by giving them a decent
Social Security oh no we have to worry
about the deficit and we spent a lot of
time trying to explain this to
Republicans but they understand this
they know the game they have an explicit
goal then that is to minimize the
responsibility that the wealthiest
people and corporations have to this
country and to allow them to take as
much as they possibly can from this
country without this country ever
spending a dime on protecting those who
are marginalized in this capitalistic
system that is their goal I want to read
a quote from Vox they said the deficit
is rising so Republicans want to cut
Social Security and Medicare the GOP
agenda is cutting corporate taxes while
also cutting government benefits and
they later on said in that article but
the GOP priorities on the deficit are
clear corporate taxes were too high and
now that they've been cut government
benefits are too generous so they must
be cut too the trade is explicit this is
not an error this is not oh they just
don't understand economics it's that
they have a particular economic vision
for America they have a vision of
America for America that had that is a
feudal society that is that takes us
back to the Gilded Age where it is
simultaneously the best of times and the
worst of times where the wealthiest are
literally living the best most
financially irresponsible lives that
they're free to live without any
responsibility to the United States of
America from which they derive all their
wealth and no responsibility to the
millions of Americans and not just this
is international right I keep saying
America but it's really an international
phenomenon capitalism obviously but they
have no responsibility and they want no
responsibility to the people from which
they draw their wealth understand that
that there are no billionaires without
the working people in America there are
no millionaires no billionaires without
every single one of us and so they have
a responsibility to this society both to
the individuals as well as the society
itself yet the Republican Party has made
it clear that they have one single goal
and that is to maximize the profits of
the wealthiest people in this country
and minimize the responsibility that
they have to this country they don't
care and and and even with defense
spending the defense spending is not so
much because of their love for America I
mean that's how they get to sell it they
get to sell it as patriotism it's not
about patriotism to them it's because
their friends their billionaire friends
they're the corporations that they're
tied to our defense contractors so even
the defense spending is not some type of
notion of responsibility to America
defense spending is just another outlay
for for economic growth and prosperity
for the wealthiest people in this
country this is who they are and I know
you who are watching this know this and
I know you're yelling at the computer
and you're yelling at the radio we know
this
no kidding Captain Obvious yeah but the
thing is is that we have people in power
particularly some Democrats who don't
really either they don't know this or
they just will willfully complicit with
this the and we have people who surround
us in media who don't see the urgency of
voting every single Republican out of
power more importantly like if you have
a problem with what Democrats are doing
you absolutely should be a part of what
the Republicans are doing and you should
absolutely want to clean house but we
have people who see what the Republican
Party is doing and still try to figure
out if they understand economics still
try to take the time to explain it to
them still take the time to say listen
you need to go read this article over
here at this explainer to help you
understand know they understand what
they're doing and they're running up the
score board for laissez-faire capitalism
neoliberalism on steroids and we're
still trying to understand whether or
not they understand the mistakes that
they're making and I'm just trying to
let you know that these aren't mistakes
this is a feature they absolutely dream
of a society where they can roll around
in their Bentley's and their Rolls
Royces and live with you know with the
episode of Simpsons that have a no goat
like literally I don't have to go to the
Simpsons golden toilet seats alright
golden toilet seats while you have
people grandmothers who have to work on
Thanksgiving Day at Walmart because they
couldn't get the day off because they
need the job because they have to
survive because their benefits are just
not enough their Social Security
benefits are just not enough and as if
this current situation that I just
described is not disgusting enough
Republicans want to exacerbate the
situation even more today's show was
made possible in part by sion games and
their new game for phone and tablet
called antidote which is an
award-winning strategy game it's all
about using vaccines to defend the human
body from bacteria and viruses it's fast
paced the graphics are amazing the game
has actually been commended by the World
Health Organization because it has a
mission to fight back against anti
vaccine misinformation so the game is
educational and fun to play download
antidote for free on your phone or
tablet in the Google Play Store or the
iOS App Store and have a blast using
vaccines and the body's immune system to
fight off deadly diseases and don't
forget to search for scion games on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram if you're
watching this on YouTube I've put the
links under the video